um are you are you like for you man like
what is motivating like your creative
process like what inspires you in 2022
is it your son is it
just like being a fan of other music
like what inspires you like when you get
into the booth you have an idea like
what is the main inspiration for you
musically nowadays these days
main inspiration for me man I I don't
know man I'm just so excited to just
give people experiences like something
that they can like attach to a memory
that they have going on in life like
that's kind of what I'm really what I
really care about right now just giving
them
one song just like you know if you
listen to my album I just want one song
for you to just take and just for you to
live with you know I mean for you to be
able to like I said attach a certain
memories to it like oh I was at this
place or I was with this girl or you
know I mean that's all I care about
right now um I've been listening to a
lot of different music that's inspiring
me um Steve lacy one of one of my
favorites you know the new Drake 21
Savage album amazing I love that album
um uh it's a lot of dope stuff what's
your album of the year my album of the
year yeah just give me three of them how
about that so you don't I mean I'll
probably say Steve Lacy just because you
know I love Melody yeah and um and then
I would say to Drake 21 her loss for
sure really already you're gonna put her
loss up there that fast yeah you're
gonna let it marinate a little bit oh I
don't need to I just heard I heard it
and I just knew it was the best meme
action of the year that too like so many
different reasons my son who's [ __ ]
eight years old
not listen to the album once sings that
part yeah because he'd be on Tick-Tock
and [ __ ] yeah YouTube and I'm like bro
how do you know this that's good he's
like Drake zesty Dad
hey yo I'm like what that's crazy
because now that is that that video game
clip where someone created Dragon yeah
you're 21 savage or drinks walking yeah
that [ __ ] is hilarious with album's
classic though I love it no it's a great
album and I think um Drake went in man
that spin about you record is so hard oh
my God they both snapped I I prefer this
over I think this is my favorite Drake
project since uh
if you're reading this
probably since if you're reading this
it's too late that's me too yeah yeah
same I always feel like when I listen to
a Drake album I'm always wanting more
but I feel like I listen to this and I'm
very I love 21 Savage so I just knew I
was like yo this is going to be the
Drake album I love I just have there's
no way him and 21 Savage and make some
whack [ __ ] just not I was so right I was
like me and Swan in the studio just like
ready for it to drop soon as it drop
press play you got a relationship with
Drake yeah how's that cool nice guy cool
guy kills me fifty thousand dollars
fifty thousand for what
we were hanging out at Harriet's at the
bar I was with Freddie Gibbs and
this was uh two years ago
when the sun's made it to the finals
shots of them Phoenix Suns
and Drake bet me
50 I said 50 000 was the bet uh uh
whether or not the Suns or The Warriors
would make it further that year this was
like maybe three three-fourths of the
way through the season I got witnesses
credible Witnesses
uh and uh yeah man just [ __ ] no way
to get a hold of Drake you know I don't
have his [ __ ] number I've dm'd him
like hey what's up with my bread bruh
yeah I mean damn I'm never gonna get my
money so when like he he made that 2K
bet on Twitch the other day with 21
Savage I'm like good luck ever getting
that money
I feel like he has a problem gambling
too yeah
me no I don't gamble no no no no he had
smart no gamble oh maybe on Mario Kart
or something like that you gamble Mario
Smash Bros yeah I will are you excited
for Super Nintendo land at Universal
coming yeah I'm excited to see what they
do I would rather go to like that I
think they're doing one I think they
have one already over in like Tokyo or
something like that'd be where you'd
want to go that's where I want to go
because if you go to Tokyo I'm not so
times your question no because actually
now I think about it because it's going
to be so
everybody's going to be there so I'll
probably have to wait
maybe I can rent out rent it out for
like one day or something yeah you're
rich uh but you get a VIP tour you know
yeah I went to Halloween Horror Nights
uh you ever been there no I never have
so the weekend had his own haunted house
oh for real yeah like he was like the
main Universal Studios Halloween Horror
Nights this year was like based around
the weekend that's crazy and his haunted
house was the best one I expected it to
be kind of
what's scary about the weekend there's
some wild [ __ ] going on in there I wish
I saw it's like being on a [ __ ] up
mushroom trip while listening to his
album it was pretty crazy